Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
The Tim Ferriss show is
brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you will find Alpha brain chewable
Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling. Kettlebells, battle
ropes, maces steel clubs.
It sounds like a torture
chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber for
self improvement and you
can see all of my favorite
gear at [inaudible] dot com
forward slash Tim. That's o,
n n I t.com forward slash Tim and
you can also get a discount on any
supplements, food products. I like
hemp force, I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on
it.com forward slash Tim,
the Tim Ferriss show is also
brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is your one stop shop for
anything. Graphic design related.
You need a logo, you need a website, you
need a business card or anything else.
You get an original design from designers
around the world who submit drafts for
you to review,
you are happy or you get your money back
and I've used 99 designs for book cover
ideas for the four hour body,
which went to Number One New York Times
for banner ads and you can check out
some of my actual
competitions@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim you can
also get a free $99 upgrade
if you want to give it a shot.
That's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to a
very special episode of the Tim Ferriss
Show where each episode I attempt to
deconstruct world class performers to find
what makes them tick,
the tools and tricks that you can
use in your daily life ranging from
professional athletes to chess prodigies
to billionaire investors to in this
episode. That's right, Arnold
Swartz and Negar the man himself,
the governor later the terminator,
the man who killed the
God Damn Predator people.
This was an amazing experience for me.
Of course there are many things
that I associate with my upbringing,
if you want to call it that
in the 80s guns and roses,
but of course there's commando, there's
Predator. The list goes on and on.
This man is a force of nature
and I had the opportunity,
the rare opportunity to visit him at
his home in southern California at the
kitchen table.
We dug into everything and I really
wanted to dig into areas that had not been
explored widely in any other interviews
that I could find and that ranges from
the art of psychological warfare. He
is a master. How did he apply that?
What phrases to use questions that he
used to get inside the heads of his,
we cover that. What was his most
lucrative movie? I'll give you a hint.
Twins. How the hell did that happen? Well,
there's a lot that goes
into the backstory of that.
How did he make millions of dollars fresh
off the boat before his acting career
took off?
A lot of people don't realize he was a
millionaire before his acting career took
off. How did that happen? We dig into it.
How did Arnold use meditation for one
year and just one year to completely reset
his brain and prime the
stage for massive success.
And of course mailing
cow balls to politicians,
but that's just the tip of the iceberg.
This was an amazing episode.
I want to let you get right
into it. The show notes, links,
all that good stuff will be found at
four hour workweek all spelled out,
four hour work,
week.com click on podcast or you can
just go to four hour workweek.com forward
slash Arnold and without further ado,
please enjoy a wild romp through
the life of Arnold Schwartzenegger
kind. Sir, I want it to start with a
thank you for welcoming me to your house,
number one.
But number two,
I felt awkward all morning because I
don't know how I should address you and I
wanted to ask you how
I should address you.
Well, are you going to visit me in any
way you want? You can call me governor,
the governor Schnitzel.
I'm old,
but I think would be right.
Go with Arnold. It's, it's, I felt like
my first year in Japan when I was 15,
cause I didn't know how to
address anybody. Uh, so I
figured we could start with
a favorite topic.
Well,
it's become a favorite topic is
I've been thinking about this,
which is big balls and cow
balls and bull testicles.
So you've mailed,
uh,
sculptures of bull testicles to
people before. Is that right?
Well, there was one incident, uh, and uh,
but the color,
this was when I was governor
and there was a, you
know, one of the leaders,
legislative leaders, John
Steinberg, uh, and I,
we both had the huge challenge. Uh,
California was hit then and norm was,
uh, you know, economic decline.
There was a worldwide recession
that was hitting us in 2008,
and everyone kind of was caught by
surprise of what effect that had, did.
All of a sudden we had $20
billion less in revenues,
therefore we had to make big cuts in
education and in various different areas
that really hit the vulnerable
citizens, um, of Cody fornia.
And so when we did the budget,
I basically sent him up before we
negotiated in know a set of balls and,
uh, and uh, you know, kind
of just be the note that say,
I hope you have that when
we negotiate the budget.